in Boston over the weekend
a bunch of satanists met up
in what is now being called the largest
gathering of satanists ever
it was called Satan Khan big conference
for satanists they're making a lot of
satanic symbols wearing lots of
pentagrams and weird goat head imagery
and horns and stuff
looking like a bunch of weirdos and
doing really bad things
they're shredding Bibles
they were they were engaging in they're
performing unbaptizing ceremonies which
is not possible baptism leaves an
indelible mark on the soul but these
Jokers think they can unbaptize you they
were
shredding pro-cop Flags you know The
Thin Blue Line blue lives matter
they were promoting transgenderism they
were promoting abortion
they had talks sins of the flesh
Satanism and self-pleasure promoting uh
what Woody Allen euphemistically called
sex with someone you love the sort of
thing that one does associated with
pornography uh they they had to talk
reclaiming the trans body
and it's it's easy to
kind of just mock these guys or even to
feel a great deal of pity for them
because you think oh these are just a
bunch of Misfit weirdos dressing up and
goat horns and making The Rock The Rock
and Roll symbol and it's no big deal but
they're promoting pretty bad stuff I
mean translating the castrating children
that's that's not great that's a bad
thing to promote uh murdering babies
through abortion
it's not great these guys raise money
for abortion clinics to kill babies so
it gets it gets pretty dark it
it'd be easy to laugh at them if the
consequences of this stuff were not so
dire and of course they uh worship the
prince of Lies the father of Lies so the
only reason I even bring this up
is not to call too much attention to
these people but
when conservatives point out that this
stuff is satanic
that these ideas that seem like they are
just ordinary political issues
we want to take down the cops abolish
the police
well we want to allow men who think
they're women to just dress up like
women and they're they really are women
we're going to establish in our law that
they're really women we want women to
have choice and have the right to
control their own bodies by murdering
their children we we just we that's what
we support and a lot of people including
on the right
think oh these are just
just political issues where you have
your opinion and I have my opinion we're
going to debate maybe meet in the middle
but no
people who are serious about these
issues
recognize that
they
they come down to Good and Evil
there is a satanic element
to lots of these issues that are being
pushed by the left Tucker Carlson may
have lost his job for pointing that out
but it's so clear
when conservatives point out that there
is a satanic element to all of these
issues you don't need to take our word
for it the satanists agree
people who actually worship
the devil and most normal people in the
middle
they
it's not that they can't wrap their head
around transgenderism or around abortion
or around defund the police they can't
wrap their head around the fact
that some people
explicitly worship the devil
they think well that's a silly
superstition
that's just a silly stupid superstition
you guys you're all Jokers okay you
people who worship the devil are Jokers
and you people who go to church or
Jokers and me a Bourgeois secular
liberal whose most important weekly
ritual is going to brunch on Sunday and
maybe going to a yoga class I'm the
reasonable one here I can't help but
point out if you look at all of human
history in every society everywhere on
Earth
you see
an acknowledgment of the devil
and
an acknowledgment of
if not the one true God at least
intuitions of the one true God and an
acknowledgment of moral reality and the
idea that some things are better than
other things
so who's the mistaken one who's the
crazy superstitious one
the the people who
are behaving and perceiving the world in
in line with how everyone has always
done so
or the handful of modern secularists who
think it's all just bunk
and we're all just bags of meat and
chemicals and our only purpose is to get
pleasure and all those higher things
they're they're just fanciful
to quote Antonin Scalia in an interview
with a New York Magazine lib journo some
years ago now she was mocking him for
being religious and he said you know
yeah I believe in God in heaven I even
believe in hell and the devil many more
intelligent people than you or me have
believed in the devil are you ready to
take the next step in your education but
struggling to fit traditional classes
into your busy schedule Grand Canyon
University's online programs are
designed to make earning your degree
easy and accessible no matter your age
or stage in life whether you're a busy
professional looking to advance your
career or a stay-at-home parent juggling
family responsibilities gcu's online
courses give you the flexibility you
need to learn on your own terms Grand
Canyon University specializes in helping
you fit your bachelor's Master's or
doctoral degree into your busy day from
scholarships to customized scheduling
your graduation team led by your own GCU
counselor provides you with the personal
support you need to succeed so why wait
if you're ready to take your education
to the next level you need Grand Canyon
University find your purpose at Grand
Canyon University one of my favorite
schools I've ever visited I've got some
colleagues actually who I met visiting
Grand Canyon University now they work
with us
gcu.edu that is
gcu.edu the pope went and visited
Hungary
Hungary strong right-wing government
doing a lot of great stuff
Pope Francis summertimes it talks a
little bit in a kind of fusing way a
papa Francesco was a misinterpreted by a
Republica Journal a newspaper in Italy
and he'll say things and then sometimes
the journalists are in fact
misinterpreting them sometimes what the
Holy Father says is somewhat ambiguous
but what he said in Hungary was not
ambiguous at all and it shocked a lot of
liberals I will translate what the Pope
says
this is a nefarious path of ideological
colonization that eliminates differences
as in the case of gender culture which
eliminate differences
or prioritizes other things reducing
freedom for example and creating an
insane right to abortion
that is always a tragic
how beautiful and
for birth and family
we have countries in Europe where the
median age is 46 or 48 years old
what if we have a country
in which the growth and uniqueness of
each individual is preserved
it's a great idea so in there he comes
out in favor of hungary's initiative to
increase birth rates in Europe comes out
against abortion articulates that this
is insane to suggest there's such a
thing as a right to abortion and he says
that gender ideology is is crazy that
it's an ideological colonization
it's contrary to reality
but this is a liberal Pope what do you
mean the liberal Pope
is opposed to abortion yes because the
church has taught consistently from day
one that abortion is completely
unacceptable we see this in the Bible we
see this in the Commandment against
committing murder
we see this in the scriptural defenses
of children we also see this in the ddk
that earliest catechism of the church
going back to the earliest days of the
church
what about gender Theory well we see
this in the Bible in the beginning God
created man both male and female created
he them we see this in the
complementarity of the sexes in the
description of marriage in Genesis and
in the gospel of Saint Matthew and we
see this throughout the history of the
church so you could say yes Pope Francis
is liberal I'm not suggesting that that
Pope Francis really is desirous of
upending church teaching on gender
ideology but he's merely constrained by
tradition I totally take the Pope in his
word I think he's sincere when he says
he thinks abortion is insane and he
thinks that gender ideology is crazy in
a colonization and he says it's good to
have young people being born
but why is it that the pope would think
that
and why would he advocate for that even
when he has a reputation as a liberal
because there is no way to overcome not
only
the clear scripture
but that that weight of History this is
why the libs have to attack history
this is why the libs have to turn your
eyes away from history
this is why the libs have to get you to
focus only on your unfettered reason and
you as an individual totally divorced
from your family
from your local community
from your nation from your democracy and
from what Chesterton would call that
that greatest democracy of all the
Democracy of the Dead which is not
merely confined to people who happen to
be walking about the Earth at this time
that
that segment is going to give you a lot
to think about it's giving me a lot to
think about even hearing it again wow
such Insight if you want all of that
Insight you've got to ring the bell
click the thing do the doodad subscribe
to the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time
[Music]
good